we need to put you back in oxygen buddy
female g3 yeah that's quite relentless
period now winter it's been very
challenging we full at the moment up to
four patients
bedlam is low I feel so sorry for the
staff West Suffolk Hospital has never
been busier and we've got pressure
bandage on his head it's among the best
performing A&E departments in England
but during 3 days here we saw how a huge
rise in demand for beds he's putting
staff and NHS systems under overwhelming
pressure I thought I had just a
straightforward chest infection over the
last three or four days maybe a week but
it's transgressed into a much heavier
infection which has room lighten your
feet Peter was one of more than 220
emergency admissions while we were at
West Suffolk around a third of everyone
who came to a ne and I talking about
kicking the until Friday so ok we wish
you luck thank you very much Peter is
not alone in needing a bed that will let
him get on thank you Peter
ok emergency admissions here are up 9%
on last year and rose more than 14
percent in January three times the
national average forcing the hospital to
expand into every corner of available
space this is a good practical example
of how the hospital's adapted to cope
with winter pressure when we were here
eight weeks ago this was the main
waiting area for the emergency
department now waiting rooms been moved
down the corridor and this has become an
escalation area so patients who have
been seen with a waiting to be admitted
to hospital come in here and that frees
up more space in the emergency
department so that ambulances can
continue to offload patients in good
time is there any house at the moment
finding beds is a daily battle and this
is the frontline the meetings where
staff discussed you can be discharged to
make room for new admissions it's been
extremely busy since the last time you
were here then it's specific special
heaters by about just after New Year we
had to open more escalation bed than
what we were anticipating the
Hospital can only open extra beds if it
has the staff and winter has taken its
toll
we've been experienced in the last few
days quite a lot of from sickness in our
staff and I think there's a degree of
people are quite exhausted we've had
quite a relentless period now or sort of
short staff and staff in deficits the
back door of the hospital is as
important as the front discharging
patients promptly is crucial
Shirley's job is to help those who need
support once they get home hello Tom
Tommy's fresh out of hospital after
becoming dehydrated following heart
surgery Shirley and an Assessor from the
local authority work out what care he
needs to remain at home how important is
it to you if someone has been
independent on his life to be back at
home very and and to have everything you
need to be able to stay resolvable 300
I'm intend on being independent I can do
everything myself
no yeah and it annoys me this scheme has
supported almost a hundred patients in
three months and freed up nearly 350 bed
days I know you're very independent and
this is what this is all about National
Health has been a a godsend to me you
know staff and everybody have been
helping me have been marvelous I kind of
give it up counts in there but I have
done 17 miles in one day keeping
patients moving through the hospital is
crucial and no one knows that better
than the porters during a winter there
has been a high demand it's a very
unpredictable demand as well when we
start the day you have actually no idea
of knowing how many patients are going
to come through the door an hour after
hour day after day
patients like Eric keep coming he's in
his 80s and here often collapsing in
Tesco's this happened yesterday road out
of the blue and what happened within
seconds that's a bit of a worry isn't it
even through
well I wasn't worried familiar at the
time because I didn't know what happened
the NHS is coped with this record demand
better than last year and while we may
not be calling it a crisis this winter
has revealed a new normal of services at
full stretch time will tell if it is
sustainable poor Kelso Sky News West
Suffolk hospital